he has a net worth of around 50 billion
dollars and is china's
second richest man jack ma is also the
founder of the e-commerce giant alibaba
which regulators have accused of using
monopolistic tactics
they have been signaling for quite some
time that changes our foot they do not
want entities to
in essence control the market alibaba
shares fell by eight percent when stock
markets opened
the investigation is part of a wider
government crackdown on china's booming
internet space
it's also yet another setback for the
alibaba group which planned a dual
listing of its ant company last month
regulators said it didn't meet
disclosure requirements
and the ipo was shelved two days before
its market debut as we all know anne's
group it's
already the largest online payment
service provider in mainland china
and still have a lot room to grow most
of the mainland
they don't use credit card and they
don't use cash anymore they
simply use a cell phone to pay
everything not only
apparel not only digital devices but
even they buy a car they use a mobile
payment
and group is the crown jewel in the
alibaba empire
the listing was expected to raise as
much as 37 billion dollars
that would have made it the world's
largest ipo since oil giant
saudi aramco listed last december the
largest ipo today
is i believe the saudi arabia oil
company which is
listed a couple of years ago at 28
billion
and sister company alibaba went public
in 2014
listing on the new york stock exchange
in a 25 billion
float this time the company chose the
domestic market in china for its debut
but the mega float is on hold for now
this latest investigation is part of the
government's escalating scrutiny of jack
ma's expanding empire
and represents heightened tensions
between chinese president xi jinping
and the billionaire in a statement the
company says it will comply with the
regulator's requests
its executives are expected to be
summoned in coming days
sarah clark al jazeera hong kong